thank you
smoke covers the skyline north of
Sudan's capital after air strikes by the
Army against positions of the rapid
support forces fighting continues at
Khartoum airport leaving a trail of
Destruction satellite pictures show
widespread damage after days of heavy
fighting flights have been suspended
preventing International mediators from
arriving
330 kilometers north of Khartoum marawi
air base is still being contested by
rival military forces with fighter jets
destroyed
the battle has intensified between
Sudan's Army and the biggest and most
powerful paramilitary Army Chief
abdulfata al-burhan and his Deputy
Muhammad hamdan dagalo who leads the
rapid support forces had been in charge
of the country since 2019.
but they disagree on how to restore
civilian rule it's unclear who now has
the upper hand with fighting around the
general command military headquarters
the rapid support forces released
footage purporting to show its troops
gaining ground with its soldiers at the
security services building
but after the Army took back control of
State TV on Monday it's called on the
rsf to turn themselves in
it is not in the interest of our
homeland to have its own countrymen
carrying arms against one another
therefore we call on them not to be part
of this conspiracy to lay down arms and
turn themselves in and then let's see if
they will consider joining the ranks of
Sudan's Armed Forces
Khartoum and other cities are now
battlefields with tanks rolling through
the streets and dead bodies strewn
across Pavements medical staff are
warning they can't reach the injured
because hospitals are under attack
there's not enough medicine food or
water
with power Cuts generators are operating
at critical levels but some are
venturing out to find supplies
we have bought six packs of noodles two
pack can feed three people for one meal
there is also salt and cake the cake
will expire tomorrow so we can have it
for dinner tonight
there's a global push to find diplomatic
resolve the U.S is urging the warring
sides to end hostilities
this morning I made calls to generals
burhan and hamedi
urging them to agree to a 24-hour
ceasefire to allow Sudanese to safely
reunite with their families and to
obtain desperately needed relief
supplies I also underscored in both
calls the responsibilities that Sudanese
fighting forces bear for ensuring the
Safety and Security of U.S and other
diplomats who are resident in Sudan as
well as for un staff and other
humanitarian partners for now it's
unclear if the two generals are willing
to Heed These requests as their Capital
City continues its descent into a war
zone rahila Muhammad Al Jazeera
let's go to hibber Morgan now she's live
for us from Khartoum and here were the
last season's fire turned out to be a
bit shaky how solid does this one look
like
well we're going to have to wait until
the uh the start of the period of a
ceasefire but when you look at the
record uh just over the past two days
when the first ceasefire uh was
announced on Sunday and then the second
on Monday both did not last people were
not able to leave their homes and even
now ahead of that ceasefire that was
agreed upon by both sides following
International pressure there is intense
airstrikes so intense that the building
where we are we're at we're forced to
stay in the basement for safety reasons
so it's not clear if both sides will
actually adhere to the ceasefire that
their top command has agreed to there's
intense abstracts ongoing we can still
hear Heavy Artillery being fired
anti-aircraft themselves being fired at
the fighter jets that are flying
overhead and we can still see that there
are some smoke coming out from some
parts of the capital of especially the
southern parts so it's clear that these
two are determined to fight until the
point when the ceasefire is supposed to
come into effect with both sides wanting
to upper hand when that ceasefire comes
into effect
and tragic video coming in showing the
suffering that people are putting up
with their University students burying a
colleague in the grounds because they
simply can't get out bring us up to
speed with what the humanitarian
situation is looking like on day four
foreign
humanitarian situation even before this
fighting started was already dire with a
third of the population in need of
assistance many people did not expect
this fighting to happen so they didn't
have extra food they didn't store water
many people in residential areas who we
spoke who we spoke to say that they're
out of clean water to drink that they're
out of food and they don't know what
they'll be having for iftar this is the
holy month of Ramadan and people saying
that they've been out of electricity for
four days now so most of the food that
they had in the fridge is no longer
usable for them to be able to cook so
the situation is quite dire and then
there are those who've been injured as a
result of the heavy shellings in
residential areas they say that they
can't access hospitals because most
hospitals are either not operational or
with very little medical staff and then
there's the issue of security on the
streets they say they can't leave their
homes so the situation the humanitarian
situation for the civilians who are
caught up in the middle of this battle
between the rsf and the Armed Forces is
quite dire many of them saying that they
don't know when this will end but they
want it to happen and so that they can
try to get some kind of medical
assistance and try to get food and water
for survival
all right thanks so much hibber Morgan
there
Abdullah lives in Khartoum with his
mother and sisters he joins us now live
from there good to have you with us so
first of all let's start with the
ceasefire how are you confident how
eager will you be to try and go out
during the ceasefire which I think
starts at six o'clock local time in in
Khartoum
yeah six o'clock local time is supposed
to be having a series fire but I don't
think that any of that is happening as
you can hear now there's a few uh shots
being taken
and I think they're trying to use each
and every hour before he receives fire
so having troubles in water electricity
food everything
um the connection between people is
getting low because people are trying
their phones are getting
shut off my phone now what I'm talking
is on two percent in my cutoff right now
so it's pretty hectic around here so how
will you survive then if you don't go
out it sounds like you're not planning
to go out to the shops
the Sudanese people like um they're
actually going out getting their stuff
up
that the bullets over their head they
don't have like they have no other
choice but to do that or they'll die
inside their houses
so they have to go out and get their
food especially in the month of Ramadan
you have to go get a lot of stuff
besides that so people are just stacking
up supplies stacking up supplies and
supplies are beginning to run out
so and then when you when you buy food I
mean how do you refrigerate it with no
electricity what are you planning to do
to you know recharge your batteries and
your phones and things like that
well some houses and some hoods have
generators so you find a whole
neighborhood uh
charging their phones in this specific
house in this house as water and this
like you know it's a mixed up thing you
never know you don't know what the truth
is you don't know like
um who has the who where uh like who
where uh what did they hit like a water
supply uh station or they hit the
electricity station I don't know maybe
the they shut it down by themselves
maybe it's tactics for the war we don't
know that but the thing is that there's
no electricity there's no water we're
just trying to handle it out as Citizens
we each other they're not no support
from no police nothing they're just
having a fight they're letting us die
and that's what's going on in Sudan
right now people are struggling
struggling these are the first four days
so right now you're not finding a lot of
struggle because like there's still some
supplies there's still some people that
have electricity have diesel they can
charge it their generators but in if
this thing continues for three four days
I think we're gonna be losing a lot of
people
medications we can't find medication
pharmacies are closed hospitals are
closed there are some people who are
sick they need medical treatment they
can't be staying at their homes they
they're dying now at their homes because
there's no medical attention there's no
hospital open so basically it's a pretty
pretty desperate hectic situation is
there any functioning Authority at any
level local Authority central government
uh ambulance services police anybody you
can call if you need help
while recalling on all the not the local
organization I'm talking about the
worldwide organization because the local
organizations um they're not paying
attention to what's going on as if
they're ignoring what's going on I'm
talk I'm talking about
um I'm calling on the ngos all the ngos
all the United Nations whatever the
humanitarian organizations they gotta
help us in the situation come see we
have to cease fire we have to stop this
because if this continues they're more
and more innocent people will die well
there's no local authorities that you
can reach out to and pick up the phone
and call someone for help
not at all not even the police if you if
if someone got robbed if you call the
police they won't uh act upon you they
won't do anything the world the Sudan is
in a mess right now
only thing we can do is pray to God that
everything is stay safe and we're
listening the second thing is that we
call out on all the humanitarian
organizations ngos you have to
put an end to the situation because it's
getting really really really bad the
first three four days right now it's bad
but it's not that bad it's gonna get
worse trust me it's gonna get worse and
they and the rsf and the military even
them they're gonna run out of supplies
and they're gonna start robbing people
and killing people and coming into
people's houses already a few have done
that and uh
Palace area the presidential Palace
um about four to five kilometers some
people I know some people that told me
that they started robbing cars started
robbing houses they take gold they took
these are the rsfs especially the rsf
rapid support uh forces they especially
because they're running out of supplies
supplies they go to houses they rob
houses whatever they can find they take
you know so it's gonna get pretty more
and right it's it's tragic tragic to
hear that Khalid we hope the situation
gets better for you and charge your
phone and stay safe thank you so much
you're welcome you're welcome